as you might know dwayne johnson is a
hollywood mainstay with so many famous
movie credits to his name that is easy
to lose count of them all
ever since he made his transition from
being the rock in the wwe to the big
screen
johnson has joined a number of ongoing
franchises
but there is one franchise for which he
is very well known
the fast and the furious since first
appearing as hobbs in fast five back in
2011
johnson went on to reprise the role four
more times including in the spin-off
film in which she co-stars with jason
statham
fast and furious presents hobbs and
shore however the only thing more well
known about johnson playing hobbs other
than him kicking butt and taking names
is a notorious beef between johnson and
mr family himself
vin diesel diesel of course has played
dominic taretto in the fast and furious
franchise from the very beginning
and continues to star in the franchise's
films including the latest installment
f9 as big of a star as the rock may be
vin diesel is basically the face of the
fast and furious franchise
so this latest unfortunate development
wasn't exactly unforeseeable
especially in light of said public beef
johnson did not appear in f9
and now he has something to say about
both that omission and whether or not
he'll appear in any other films within
the franchise going forward
two things of note worth mentioning
before discussing dwayne johnson's
future in the fast and furious movie
franchise
one there are supposedly only two more
movies left in the franchise before the
story
wraps two vin diesel recently tried to
explain the feud between him and dwayne
johnson
in a recent interview with men's health
diesel passed off the beef as
intentional on his part
diesel said i could give a lot of tough
love not fellinisk but i would do
anything i'd have to do in order to get
performances in anything i'm producing
while doing an interview alongside emily
blunt with the hollywood reporter to
promote
jungle cruise their upcoming disney film
johnson responded bluntly
i laughed and i laughed hard i think
everyone had a laugh at that and i'll
leave it to that
and by leave it at that he meant expand
on the situation
and that i've wished them well i wish
them well on f9 and i wish them the best
of luck on fast 10 and fast 11
and the rest of the fast and furious
movies they do that will be without me
in other words it certainly seems like
johnson is done with the fast and
furious franchise permanently
emily blunt sarcastically chimed in
about diesel saying
just thank god he was there thank god he
carried you through that
fellini-esque johnson said in response
just so we're clear fellinis could refer
to the famous italian director
who created bizarre abstract films that
were more like works of art
you know just like the fast franchise
right there was plenty of space in
diesel's somewhat self-serving
explanation of the beef for johnson to
leave it squashed
but his comments drawing the press
junket for jungle cruise suggests
hatchet burying isn't in the cards for
him and vin
while he never provided anything close
to the full sherman in his response to
questions
about his future with the fast and
furious franchise his obvious disdain
for diesel's comments
not to mention the sarcastic edition
from blunt suggests it would take
quite an overture to rope him back into
the family it's not like he's really
hurting for the work either
johnson just completed what he described
as one of the most physically and
mentally demanding experiences of his
career
preparing for and filming black adam and
given the anticipation for that
particular feature it seems likely he'll
become a mainstay with the dc extended
universe
for the foreseeable future long before
that superhero flick reaches screens
however
his starring turn in the long-awaited
jungle cruise is set to debut
the house of mao certainly hopes that
jungle cruise will become the next
pirates of the caribbean
in which case train johnson's frank
skipper wolf will be the next captain
jack sparrow
that sounds like another franchise role
if we've ever heard one
jungle cruise hits theaters on friday
july 30th
and will also be available on disney
plus premiere access
for 29.99 check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more luba
videos about fellini-esque situations
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single fellini-esque i mean a single
one